- We've been talking quite a bit about this water crisis
in Flint, Michigan.
Outrageous water crisis that may actually
be criminal in nature.
Lead in the water after the source for the town's water
was switched to the Flint River
has potentially poisoned up to 8,000 children.
So I was thrilled to hear that the Michigan Senate
came together and they were able to push a bill through,
which does absolutely nothing about the water crisis
in Flint, but instead bans anal sex,
so-called sodomy ban.
It it even more insane
because Michigan already has a sodomy ban
and obviously these bans are ridiculous
because the 2003 Supreme Court case
of Lawrence v. Texas declares
sodomy bans are unconstitutional in all states.
So let me say this as concisely as possible, Louis.
Instead of helping the people being poisoned
by their own water
as a result of a government decision
to save some money,
Michigan Republicans are spending time and money
to uphold a sodomy ban
that number one, already exists,
and number two, is impossible to enforce
and unconstitutional.
What a great use of time from our friends,
the Republicans in Michigan, huh?
- I think the saddest part about this is
probably the majority of their constituents,
maybe not constituents,
maybe just their supporters,
-[David] Okay.
- Probably have no idea that this is even happening.
-[David] Maybe not.
- And
I just don't understand
who gets up in the face of a water crisis like this
and says,
"This is important. We need to focus on this."
-[David] Let's ban anal. Yeah.
- And I'm gonna talk on the Bonus Show
about Obama's Clean Water Proposal
-[David] Yeah.
- Which at a federal level would help address
what's going on over there.
- You might wonder how they even pass
such a ridiculous bill.
This might not shock you.
They attached it to an animal rights bill
which was trying to keep pets out of the hands
of animal abusers,
and they put in a section about beastiality
and then they said two adults having anal sex
is basically like abusing an animal.
And the language specifically is:
a person who commits the abominable
and detestable crime against nature, sodomy,
either with mankind, or with any animal,
is guilty of a felony, punishable by imprisonment
for not more than 15 years.
Politics at its worst.
What is more abominable and detestable,
anal sex between consenting adults,
or subjecting an entire community
to toxic water to save a few bucks?
You decide, Louis.
I'm glad they have their priorities straight.
- Oh, also ten children died as a result of that.
-[David] Right.
- Yeah.
- Ban anal, Louis, ten children died from water.
- Yes. So I think
we don't really need to comment any more on that.
I think we know
Which one is more detestable.
- Yeah. Basically speaks for itself.
Absolutely disgusting.